By the way, Mr. Fumi, there is someone at the end of the road
.
Let's get rid of that guy--I won't take his life, or will he take everything except his life?
Do you mind if I stop him?
I understand if I use the magic of support
The root of my power is the
baizen Read the reasoning once more Wake up the mayfly and wake me up
Yes, Mirage, the
road that can't start, the
guy riding that carriage from another merchant  Did
you sell them to your
friends
? So what are
you going to do with them?  That's why I knew it in one shot
. I'm a pitiful adventurer who was attacked by that villainous Shield Hero by the gk troupe.
Up wagon to have you die Philo
Are you hungry
4 oven